meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
nachdem sich die Welt Öffentlichkeit in
den vergangenen 18 Monaten daran
gewöhnen musste dass in Europa wieder
ein brutaler von Russland entfesselter
kriegt hobbt zwingen Sie ein anderes
gewaltsames Ereignis ihr Augenmerk auf
Afrika zu richten und zu Erstaunen
vieler Außenstehender wurden von den
dortigen Aggressoren dabei auch Russland
fehlenden geschwenkt ganz genau die
Bedeutung des Staatsstreichs in Niger
geht nicht nur weit über Afrika hinaus
nein es handelt sich auch um viel mehr
als die für den gestauchten
kontinentypische Machtübernahme durch
eine militärhundert ja es ist wahr das
Niger eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt
ist aber trotzdem verfügte es über eine
anerkannte Demokratie es hatte bis vor
kurzem noch eine demokratisch gewählte
Regierung die z.B mit internationaler
Hilfe in islamischen dschadismus
eindämmen wollte der die Sahelzone in
eine Hölle auf Erden verwandelt in
diesem Sinne war der Niger der große
Verbündete des bestens im Herzen dieser
Region über die wir sogar ein eigenes
Video gedreht haben dass ich euch
verlinken werde
es euch unbedingt an um noch mal den
weiteren Gesamtkontext Ereignisse zu
verstehen alle Bemühungen der
demokratischen Regierung und ihrer
westlichen Verbündeten einen Hort der
Stabilität in der Sahelzone zu errichten
wurden jedoch durch den Staatsstreich
Ende Juli zu nicht der gemacht die an
die Macht gekommene militär-kontan nimmt
zwar immer noch Hilfe aus dem Ausland in
Anspruch aber sie hat sich ganz andere
Verbündete ausgesucht mega es kommt da
bittet die russische wagnergruppe um
Hilfe da ihr eine militärische
Intervention droht aber Moment mal ist
hier von einer militärischen
Intervention einer westlichen macht die
Rede um den wachsenden Einfluss des
Krems in Afrika einzudämmen Fehlanzeige
es ist die Eco was die intervenieren
möchte Eco was steht für economy
Community auf westafrican States
dabei handelt es sich um die
Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
westafrikanischer Staaten die einfach
nicht mehr bereit ist einen weiteren
Militärputsch zur tolerieren und die
Rückkehr von Mohammed barsum dem
abgesetzten demokratischen Präsidenten
Nigers fordert und genau deswegen werden
in Afrika wieder die Kriegstrommeln
geschlagen 10 August 2023
westafrikanische Staatsoberhäupter
aktivieren bereitschaftsgruppe um auf
den Putsch in Niger zu reagieren 14
August 2023 nigerianisches Militär
bereitet sich auf ecovaseinsatz in Niger
vor das Schlimmste aber es ist dass
diese militärische Intervention über
Niger hinausgehen und einen regionalen
Konflikt auslösen könnte der sich auf
mehrere Länder ausbreitet so hat es der
Sprecher der militärhundert Oberst aber
du ab Drama ausgedrückt
immer die Forstwirte diese
hat nicht damit gezögert eine
ausländische Macht zu beschuldigen einen
Angriff gegen Niger anzustiften und
vorzubereiten damit meint er natürlich
Frankreich den ehemaligen Kolonialherrn
des Landes tatsächlich hat die
militärhundert alle militärischen
Vereinbarungen zwischen Niger und
Frankreich aufgekündigt und die
Regierung macron hat lediglich erklärt
dass sie die Eco was Intervention
unterstütze moralisch nicht militärisch
ihr seht also dass das was ich dein
Afrika aufgetan hat nicht einfach ein
neuer Stellvertreter Krieg zwischen den
besten und Russland ist es sind die
großen demokratischen afrikanischen
Länder die endlich selbst für eine
friedliche und freiheitliche Ordnung auf
dem Kontinent sorgen möchten und den
Kremmen mitsamt seiner Latein dabei als
Kriegstreiber sehen wir haben über
dessen Macht spielen Afrika ja schon
mehrere Videos gedreht und davor gewarnt
dass eine Situation wie nun im Niger
eintreten könnte wenn Moskau nicht
Einhalt geboten wird ich werde euch
diese Videos natürlich verlinken nun ist
das Kind aber in den Brunnen gefallen es
ist noch nicht ertrunken aber es
schreibt nach Hilfe und deswegen werden
wir heute alle folgende Fragen
beantworten wie konnte es überhaupt so
weit kommen was sind die Hintergründe
dieses Staatsstreichs welche Rolle
spielte Russland bei all dem inwieweit
ist Europa betroffen und vor allem wie
viele Länder könnte dieser Konflikt noch
mit in den Abgrund reißen gibt es Wege
aus dieser Misere das heutige Video hat
übrigens in kognie möglich gemacht ein
Sponsor der euch aktiv vor einer anderen
Misere schützen kann dem Datenmissbrauch
durch sogenannte data Broker das sind
datenmakler die unsere persönlichen
Daten über alle Netz abgreifen und
danach nicht nur ein seriöse Unternehmen
verkaufen sondern auch ein Betrüger
diese Betrüger bombardieren uns dann mit
unerwünschten Anrufen SMS und E-Mails
oder versuchen uns da auszunehmen leider
haben wir keine Kontrolle darüber an wen
unsere Daten verkauft werden aber die
data Broker sind gesetzlich dazu
verpflichtet unsere Daten zu löschen
wenn wir sie dazu auffordern das Problem
dabei es gibt Tausende von ihnen oft ist
der Antragsprozess absichtlich
kompliziert gestaltet deswegen
resignieren viele Menschen einfach und
lassen den ganzen Schmuck passiv über
sich ergehen Herr Sponsor dieses Videos
inkognit biete jedoch genau hierfür eine
Lösung inkognit übernimmt die Aufgabe
bei den data Brokern aufzuräumen und die
Löschanträge zu stellen um uns vor
Betrugsversuchen zu schützen du meldest
dich einfach bei inkognit an beauftragt
sie in deinem Namen die lösch-einträge
durchzusetzen und verfolgst dann bequem
auf eine übersichtlichen Dashboard wie
deine Daten nach und nach aus dem Netz
verschwinden ohne einen solchen Service
wäre es für einen normalen Menschen
nahezu unmöglich diese Löschanträge
selbst zu bearbeiten und sich vor Betrug
zu schützen also tu was gutes für deine
datenhygiene und schau dir in KODi über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung an
außerdem mit dem Promo Code politik.de
erhältst du auch noch 60% Rabatt wenn du
zu den ersten 100 gehörst die ihn nutzen
und falls Du uns etwas nicht tun
möchtest ebenfalls in der Beschreibung
unter diesem Video findest du einen
Spenden mit dem du unsere Arbeit auf
freiwilliger Basis unterstützen kannst
an dieser Stelle schon mal vielen
herzlichen Dank an alle edlen Spender so
und wenn ihr das erledigt habt werden
wir auch eine Reise aufbrechen in die
wohnt abgefuckteste und am meisten
verfluchte Region des Krisen geplagten
afrikanischen Kontinents die Sahelzone
die letzte Demokratie der Sahelzone
die Sahelzone ist ein schmaler Streifen
Land südlich der Wüste Sahara der von
extremer Armut geprägt ist vier Länder
befinden sich im zentrumesser heilzone
dies sind von West nach Ost Mali Burkina
Faso Liga und schad sie alle haben
mehrere Dinge gemeinsam zunächst einmal
handelt es sich bei allen diesen Ländern
um Binnenländer außerdem wird in allen
vier Ländern französisch gesprochen so
dass ihr wahrscheinlich schon erraten
könnt welches Land dort mal die
Kolonialmacht war außerdem handelt es
sich mehrheitlich um muslimische Länder
und noch etwas haben sie gemeinsam sie
alle werden derzeit vom Militär regiert
nachdem der Staat streicht der 7
nigerischen Republik ein Ende gesetzt
hat und ja mehr als einer von euch wird
jetzt denken okay mag wenn Niger 1960
von Frankreich unabhängig wurde sind das
63 Jahre und sieben Republiken also nun
Jahre pro Republik das klingt doch gar
nicht mal so schlecht ja das mag sich so
anhören aber ich möchte euch versichern
Stabilität und nieder sind zwei Wörter
die normalerweise nicht Hand in Hand
gehen
und dennoch scheint es seit 2010 eine
Veränderung gegeben zu haben damals
wurde durch eine Militärputsch zugunsten
der Demokratie Präsident mama du Tanja
aus dem Amt getrennt dieser wurde zwar
ebenfalls zunächst demokratisch gewählt
wollte Niger deine aber in ein
autoritäres Regime verwandeln um seine
Macht nicht mehr abgeben zu müssen er
wollte die Demokratie im Land also
wieder abschaffen seine Enthaftung und
die Rückkehr zu einem demokratischen
System wurde von der internationalen
Gemeinschaft unterstützt du führte zu
Errichtung der 7 Republik während dieser
sollte dann 2021 der erste friedliche
Machtwechsel zwischen zwei Präsidenten
stattfinden
kein schlechtes Zeichen also dennoch hat
in der Sahelzone im letzten Jahrzehnt
eine andere ernsthafte Bedrohung Einzug
gehalten die die gesamte Region
destabilisiert die Rede ist vom
islamischen Dschihadismus der religiöse
Fanatismus findet seine Soldaten unter
den verzweifelten und auf Hungernden
Bewohnern dieser sahel-länder es sind
Menschen die an einem der schlimmsten
Orte der Welt geboren wurden und die
fiatisten versprechen Ihnen sowohl eine
bessere Zukunft auf Erden als auch wenn
sie sich im Krieg verheißen lassen im
Paradies ihr wisst wovon die Rede ist
diese ganzen Jungfrauen und so das
Problem ist natürlich das so gesagt all
diese Männer ziemlich geil sind auf die
versprochenen Jungfrauen oder zumindest
auf die irdische Beute die sie ihren
Andersgläubigen Mitmenschen rauben oder
durch Unterdrückung Abpressen können
nicht so geil sind sie auf die gängige
Wirtschaftsform in der Region
ärmliches Subsistenz Landwirtschaft von
der mehr als 80% der nigerischen
Bevölkerung leben die extremut betrifft
sogar fast die Hälfte aller Einwohner
des Landes sage und schreibe 71 % der
Nigeria können weder lesen noch
schreiben 2015 wurde Flieger als das
Land mit den meisten Analphabeten auf
der Erde eingestuft und diese
Horrorzahlen haben sich in den
vergangenen 13 Jahren der siebten
Republik kaum verändert wir sprechen
über Daten die denen der Nachbarländer
Mali und Burkina Faso sehr ähnlich sind
und siehe da in beiden Ländern gab es in
den letzten drei Jahren staatsstreicher
die den dortigen Demokratien ein Ende
setzten in Mali im Jahr 2021 und in
Burkina Faso im Jahr 2022 in beiden
Fällen ergriff das Militär die Macht und
zwar unter dem Vorwand jetzt haltet euch
fest dem sie hat Dispos ein Ende zu
setzen das Ergebnis war jedoch das
genaue Gegenteil ihr seht euch mal diese
Karte des US-Unternehmen straight vor
über gewalttätige Vorfälle in der
Sahelzone zwischen August 2021 und
August 2022 an
der Krieg der Putschisten gegen den
schwertismus hat noch mehr Gewalt
ausgelöst im Jahr 2022 stieg die Zahl
der dschihadistischen Todesopfer in der
Sahelzone um sage und schreibe 75% auf
über 10.000 es herrscht Chaos und die
militärhunter in Mali hat sich an die
Wagner Söldner gewandt in Burkina Faso
kontrolliert die Regierung kommt 40% des
Landes in Niger ist die Situation nicht
so extrem aber die gleichen
journalistischen Gruppen die in Mali und
Burkina sind auch dort aktiv es handelt
sich um Al-Kaida unter Ash Ableger aber
auch Boko Haram oder islamische Staat
direkt terrarisieren das Land in
Grenzgebiet zum Nigeria ständig dennoch
im Gegensatz zu Burkina Fasern Mali war
das letzte Jahr im Niger das am
wenigsten tödliche seit 2018 die Frage
lautet also was ist der Grund für diesen
Unterschied nun nichts geringeres als
der Ansatz den die Regierung des
gestürzten Präsidenten mohammed war so
verfolgte seine Strategie besteht aus
mehreren Schritten erstens die westliche
Militärhilfe die vor allem von
Frankreich und den USA geleistet wird
zweitens die Veränderung der staatlichen
Dienstleistungen in den am stärksten
benachteiligten Regionen und drittens
weitere Initiativen die ebenso gegen den
Krieg gegen den Journalismus gerichtet
wie offensichtlich umstritten sind Niger
Mohammed bazoom lässt Terroristen frei
um den Dialog zu eröffnen der von basum
unterstützt deeskalationsplan versprach
Jihadisten die ihre Waffen niedergelegt
haben wieder in die Gesellschaft zu
integrieren im Grunde also Dialog im
Tausch gegen Waffenstillstand Freiheit
im Tausch gegen Frieden klar aus
westlicher Sicht ist ist eine schlechte
Idee mit Terroristen zu verhandeln es
bedeutet dass man ihre Erpressung
nachgibt und Anreize für neue Anschläge
geschafft durch die sie endlos immer
mehr und mehr Zugeständnisse erreichen
wollen
[Musik]
in einem Land weniger müssen jedoch die
tatsächliche Macht des Staates und die
Stärke der Terrorgruppen gegeneinander
abgewogen werden wenn dieser Kampf
ausgewogen ist könnte ein Krieg einen
Schrecken ohne Ende eine Katastrophe für
die Bevölkerung bedeuten es müssen also
andere Wege erkundet werden aber
natürlich gibt es da noch diejenigen die
nicht dazu bereit sind auch nur das
kleinste Zeichen von Schwäche zu
tolerieren so rechtfertigte der neue
nigerische Präsident generale omaciani
seinen Staatsstreich mit der angeblichen
Verschlechterung der Sicherheitslage
durch den sicherheitismus
das ist der
progressivabi es handelt sich um die
gleiche Ausrede die die putisten in Mali
und Burkina Faso vorgebracht haben die
miserablen Erfahrungen aus diesen
Ländern und die guten Daten aus Niger
machen jedoch deutlich dass diese
Rechtfertigung nur vorgeschoben ist es
muss also etwas anderes hinter dem
Putzen die Frage lautet deswegen was
genau nun möglicherweise ist fast dran
an den Gerüchten außerzeit vor dem
Putsch das general chiani als Chef der
Präsidentengarde abgesetzt werden sollte
ganz genau es war die Präsidentengarde
selbst also die Truppe die den
Präsidenten eigentlich schützen sollte
die Präsident war Zoom aus dem
amputschte und ihn anschließend als
Geiselnahme tja und genau deswegen
stellen viele afrikanische
Regierungschefs ihre präsidentengarten
lieber aus ausländischen Feldern
zusammen der Kommandeur der nigerischen
Präsidenten Garde selbst Nigeria
ernannte sich also schlicht und einfach
zum neuen Präsidenten und forderte dann
die Armee des Landes auf sich ihm
anzuschließen oder die Konsequenzen zu
tragen und schaut euch an was die
Generäle dann getan haben die nigerische
Armee unterstützt den Putsch gegen den
Pro westlichen Führer um einen Blutbad
zu verhindern aber gut auch das ist
natürlich nur ein vorgeschobenergrund
letztendlich handelt es sich schlicht
und einfach nur um Militärs die einen
Staatsstreich inszenieren um die Macht
im starte und seine Ressourcen selbst zu
übernehmen weil sie sich vorher
anscheinend nicht in zufriedenstellendem
Maße bereichern konnten nichts Neues
unter der brütenden Sonne des afrik
anischen Kontinents also dennoch meine
Liebe wieso Politik Community diesmal
sind sie auf Granit gestoßen bzw auf die
direkte und harte Ablehnung eine
regionalen Organisation wie ECOWAS eine
Organisation die bereit zu sein scheint
alles zu tun um die Demokratie in
negative herzustellen und es wäre nicht
das erste Mal dass dies geschieht
aufgepasst
[Musik]
handelsunion inklusive Militär
ecovas ist eine Organisation die aus 15
westafrikanischen Ländern besteht
darunter eben auch Niger ursprünglich
handelt es sich um eine Organisation mit
dem wirtschaftlichen Ziel einen
gemeinsamen handelsblock zu bilden also
so ähnlich wie auch die EU als
Europäische Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
angefangen hat aber Moment mal wenn die
Eco was hat auch Friedenstruppen in der
Region mobilisiert und in Zeiten großer
Instabilität in den Mitgliedsländern
interveniert während der letzten 30
Jahre wurden sie ins Sierra Leone Guinea
oder Elfenbeinküste Liberia Mali und
Gambia aktiv
die letzten Militärintervention der Eco
was fand 2017 in Gambia statt dort
machte nach zwei Jahrzehnten im Amt der
abgewählte Präsident jaja jamaee keine
großen Anstalten die Macht an Adama
Barrow abzugeben der die
Präsidentschaftswahlen gewonnen hatte
die ECOWAS bildete eine Koalition aus
Truppen aus dem szenegal Ghana und
Nigeria und marschierte in Gambia ein
jaja jamed trat nach drei Tagen zurück
und die Demokratie wurde wieder
hergestellt trotzdem mega ist nicht
Gambia flächenmäßig handelt es sich um
ein 100 mal größeres Land mit rund 25
Millionen Einwohner und verfügt nicht
nur über zahlenmäßig stärker
Streitkräfte und 20.000 Mann nein diese
wurden auch jahrelang vom Westen
ausgebildet wie mindestens fünf
Mitglieder der nigerischen Kunter wurden
von den USA ausgebildet aus den von
Wikileaks veröffentlichten
diplomatischen Korrespondenzen geht
hervor dass ein leutnantiani dafür
ausgewählt wurde von 2009 bis 2010 ein
einjähriges internationales Anti Terror
stippendiaten Programm an der
nationalverteidigungsuniversität in
Washington bis zu absolvieren das ist
ein beunruhigender Trend und ein Zeichen
dafür wie schlecht unsere nationalen
sicherheitsausgaben auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent verteilt sind
schrieb US-Senator Chris Murphy die USA
setzen sicherheitshilfe und militärische
Ausbildung in afrikanischen Ländern
südlich der Sahara zu großzügig eine
damit bringen sie die Vereinigten
Staaten in eine Position in der sie in
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und
feindseliges Verhalten lokaler
Sicherheitspartner verwickelt sind so
Elias Josef ein forschungsanalyst des
Simpson Centers convention de face
program unsere Erfahrungen in der
Sahelzone sollten uns zur besonderen
Vorsicht mahnen über viele Jahre hinweg
haben wir eine bemerkenswerte Reihe von
putschen sowie eine Verschlechterung der
Sicherheitslage mit dem Anstieg der
Militanz islamistische Aufstände und
kriminelle Netzwerke erlebt ich kann nur
sehr schwer auf einen einzigen Erfolg
hinweisen der eine Fortsetzung dieses
Kurses rechtfertigen würde eine
militärische Intervention in
Niederösterreich also eine hochgradig
komplexe Angelegenheit und würde viele
weitere Risiken mit sich bringen das
erste Risiko ist das Leben von Präsident
Person der sich nicht im Exil sondern in
den Händen der Putschisten befindet
westliche Amtsträger Niger Hund da waren
sie würde den abgesetzten Präsidenten
nach einer Militärintervention töten
mittlerweile kündigten sie an ihn sogar
vor ein Tribunal zu stellen wohl aus
Propaganda gründen und als
faustformisten wollen den abgesetzten
Präsidenten Mohammed bazoom wegen
Hochverrat anklagen
außerdem fragen sich sicher viele von
euch warum die Eco was jetzt so
entschlossen und selbstbewusst
gegenüberliege auftritt wurde vor kurzem
auch in Mali und Burkina Faso ähnliche
Putsche stattgefunden haben nun der
Schlüssel zu all dem liegt bei einer
Person bola tinobo er ist seit meiner
letzten Jahres der neue Präsident
Nigerias wir haben erst vor kurzem über
ihn und die jüngsten Entwicklungen und
Turbulenzen in Nigeria ein eigenes Video
gedreht dass ihr euch über den Link
hinter den e-symbol oben rechts bzw in
der Videobeschreibung ansehen könnt der
neue nigerianische präsidentinubo hat
nämlich auch genug Zeit dazu gehabt um
Anfang Juli zum Präsidenten der ecovas
aufzusteigen eine repräsentative
Position von der aus er diese Botschaft
bei seiner Angst Entführung verkündete
cool
in seiner Rede verteidigte er auch die
Demokratie die Freiheit und die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und all das ist viel
mehr als nur tinobus wolklingende Worte
während einer feierlichen Rede nein es
handelt sich um nichts Geringeres als
die zentrale Agenda des neuen
nigerianischen Präsidenten innerhalb der
ecovas damit verkündete er der ganzen
Welt dies ist die neue geopolitische
Richtung für den afrikanischen Kontinent
[Musik]
schließlich dürfen wir nicht vergessen
welch enormen Einfluss nigeria hat
Gesprächen hier von einem Land mit
gewaltigen Rohstoffvorkommen und einer
Bevölkerung von 230 Millionen Menschen
bis 2030 soll diese gar auf 300
Millionen anwachsen Nigeria wäre dann
das dritte bevölkerungsreichste Land der
Welt größer als die ehemalige
Sowjetunion neben Nigeria werden auch
die beiden anderen größten afrikanischen
Mächte Ägypten und Südafrika dass ich
sowieso in einer hoffnungslosen
Abwärtsspirale des Niedergangs befindet
wie neben Akteure erscheinen es ist also
kein Wunder dass Abuja nur die führende
und dominante Stimme der ecovas ist
Abuja ist übrigens die Hauptstadt
Nigerias nicht die Riesen Metropole
Lagos tja und die Hauptstadt
aber genug Erdkunde Unterricht für heute
abgesehen von der Sorge dass niege das
gleiche Schicksal die Mali und China
Phase erleiden und die Gewalt in der
Region eskalieren könnte will Nigeria
also seine Rolle als regionale
Führungsmacht und Garant einer neuen
Stabilität in Afrika wahrnehmen
Eingriff in die Demokratie in Niger ist
für ecovas inakzeptabel die Einmischung
des Militärs in die demokratische
Staatsführung ist nirgendwo akzeptabel
und schon gar nicht auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent die nubu
bekräftigte die Position der regionalen
Organisation kein versuchter
Einschüchterung oder Schikane von
Präsident Mohammed bazoom durch die
Militär herunter in Niger zu akzeptieren
das Timing der Putschisten in ihr Armee
hätte also schlechter nicht sein können
Sie putschten ausgerechnet nur drei
Wochen nach die nubus starker rede
gerade zu einem Provokation solange die
Diplomatie also erfolglos bleibt werden
die militärischen Vorbereitungen
weitergehen die Glaubwürdigkeit von wohl
alt genug wo steht auf dem Spiel
Eco was Kontingent für Invasion in Niger
kann bis zu 25000 Mann betragen mehr als
die Hälfte des Kontingenz sollen Nigeria
Stellen der Senegal die Elfenbeinküste
und Berlin haben ebenfalls bestätigt
dass sie Truppen sind werden tja und
dann gebe es noch zwei weitere Länder
mit Truppen vor Ort eines davon ist
Frankreich das Problem der ehemalige
Kolonialherr wird von den pochisten als
Sündenbock benutzt alles was eniger
schief läuft schieben Sie auf die
Franzosen in der Tat haben die
Putschisten sogar die französische
Botschaft angegriffen und die Regierung
macron beschuldigt Terroristen auf
freien Fuß zu setzen und kurz nach ihrer
Machtübernahme fühlten die Putschisten
ein ganzes Fußballstadion mit ihren
Anhängern indem sie dann eine makabere
Propaganda Show veranstalteten die
grünende Menschenmenge schwenkte
Russland Fähnchen und jubelte als ein
mit den französischen Nationalfarben
bemalter Hahn enthauptet wurde das gibt
euch sicherlich eine kleine Vorstellung
von der Feindseligkeit die sie gegenüber
Frankreich hegen
und an dieser Stelle fragte ich sicher
wie zum Teufel plötzlich mitten in
Afrika so schnell tausende von
russischen auftauchen konnten ich meine
sowas wird üblicherweise nicht an jeder
Straßenecke verkauft irgendwie muss das
doch von etwas längerer und weiter
entfernter Hand vorbereitet worden sein
oder nun wie ich bereits erwähnte haben
wir einen komplettes Video darüber
gedreht wie der Krimis systematisch die
französische Präsenz in Afrika bekämpft
und zwar mit Erfolg das haben wir damals
schon vorher gesagt und nun hat es sich
bewahrheitet die Gallier unterhalten die
niemals war immer noch ein ständigen
Stützpunkt damit Kampfjet bedrohnen und
1.500 Soldaten ausgestattet ist und die
Regierung marco hat erklärt dass sie die
Bemühung der Eco was unterstützt war so
und wieder an die Macht zu bringen aber
das ist auch kein Wunder schließlich
will Frankreich im Niger nicht nur die
Journalismus bekämpfen nein es unterhält
auch gewisse wirtschaftliche Interessen
im Jahr 2022 war Niger für die EU mit
einem Anteil von 25% der zweitgrößte
Lieferant von Natur uranern es würde den
Rahmen dieses Videos sprengen das
komplette schmutzige urangeschäft im
[__] auseinanderzunehmen dazu machen
wir lieber ein eigenes Video also Abo
und glücklich nicht vergessen damit ihr
es nicht verpasst an dieser Stelle nur
so viel die beiden größten Uran
Bergbauunternehmen in Niger sind so mehr
und kombinar zusammen fördern sie über
90% des nigerischen Urans und zwar seit
der Unabhängigkeit des Landes von
Frankreich im August 1960 an dieser
Stelle kommt aber der Clou an der ganzen
Geschichte bei beiden Unternehmen
handelt es sich um Tochtergesellschaften
des französischen Staatskonzerns Ariva
bzw seines neuen nuklear
brennstoffzweigs zu oral-bar 2017 in den
sogenannten Oranien Gates Skandal
verwickelt die französische
finanzstaatsanwaltschaft leitete eine
Ermittlungsverfahren wegen Bestechung
ausländischer Amtsträger privater
Korruption und krimineller Verschwörung
im Zusammenhang mit dem Verkauf von Uran
aus Niger ein doch der Ermittlungen
verliefen natürlich im Sande hierzu muss
man wissen dass das Geschäft zwischen so
mehr und kommunak auf der einen und der
nigerischen Regierung auf der anderen
Seite vollkommen im Verborgenen abläuft
und zwar schon seit seinem Anfang in den
60er Jahren alles wird absolut geheim
gehalten aber eine Zahl ist dennoch
durchgerutscht die Republik niege erhält
von allen Einnahmen von so mehr und
komina nur 5,5% an konzessionszahlungen
ganz genau die Franzosen selbst
streichen
94,5% ein sie verfügen quasi über eine
Lizenz zum Geld drucken daher ist es
nicht verwunderlich dass orano versucht
dieses Bombengeschäft so gut und so
lange wie möglich am Leben zu halten
5 mai 2023 Niger Abkommen mit dem
französischen orano über die Ausbeutung
von Uran vorkommen bis 2040
unterzeichnet tja schon wieder
schlechtes Timing diesmal auf Seiten der
Franzosen da schließt man schon so einen
bombendeal ab und keine zwei Monate
später wird einem der Vertragspartner
weggepusht und es dürfte klar sein dass
Frankreich ein Interesse hat weiterhin
Uran aus dem Niger zu beziehen mit einer
Jahresproduktion von 3000 Tonnen ist das
Land der viertgrößte Natur orange
Produzent der Welt ja und jetzt kommt
der große Plot fest denn trotz all dem
ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass kein
einziger französischer Soldat
losmarschieren wird um die Militär
herunter zu stürzen natürlich werden
sich an dieser Stelle jetzt viele von
euch fragen wieso denn das sind diese
französischen Soldaten nicht dort um
französische Interessen wie z.B die Uran
Beschaffung sicherzustellen nur
vielleicht haben einige von euch ja
Meldungen wie diese gesehen erste August
2023 der Afrika Russland Gipfel scheint
einige unerwartete Ergebnisse
hervorgebracht zu haben Burkina Faso mal
haben alle Uran und goldexporte nach
Frankreich und in die Vereinigten
Staaten verboten in einer Zeit in der
immer mehr Kernenergie genutzt wird hält
der Westen nicht mehr viele Trümpfe in
der Hand der Punkt ist diese Meldungen
sind falsch der Uranabbau und Export aus
dem Niger nach Frankreich bleibt von den
Putschisten unangetastet und das hat
gleich mehrere Gründe zum einen ist der
nigerische Staat egal von wem er gerade
geführt wird von der Uran und
Goldförderung abhängig sie machen
zusammen und 60% Exporte des Landes aus
und der Hauptabnehmer ist eben immer
noch Frankreich auch wenn langfristig
China in Frage kommt nie gehabt 2019
allein mit uranexporten und 300
Millionen Dollar verdient was etwa 5 %
der Staatseinnahmen entspricht einem
wegbrechen dieser wichtigen
Devisenquelle wäre aber nicht nur für
den Staatshaushalt nein die Aussetzung
des Uran und Goldabbaus könnte auch die
weitere Exploration und Erschließung
neuer Vorkommen im Land behindert ein
Blick ins benachbarte genährt dürfte den
neuen Machthabern als abschreckendes
Beispiel genügen im Jahr 2021 brachen
die dort bauxit-exporte praktisch
vollkommen zusammen nach dem Oberst Mama
die dumboja den Präsidenten Alpha Conde
gestürzt hatte vor diesen stahlstreich
deckte das Land rund 20% des weltweiten
bauxitmarktes ab eine Aussetzung der
nigerischen Uran und goldexporter nach
Frankreich könnte sich aber auch auf
andere Bereiche der dortigen Wirtschaft
auswirken die vom Rohstoffgeschäft
direkt oder indirekt abhängen im
industriellen Uranbergbau beispielsweise
sind rund 4000 Menschen beschäftigt im
handwerklichen und kleinen Goldbergbau
mehr als 500.000 wenn sich der Bausektor
verlangsamt oder zum Stillstand kommen
sollte würde dies zu einem Rückgang des
Wirtschaftswachstums einer Zunahme der
Armut und sozialen Unruhen führen
schließlich ist Niger bereits jetzt
eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt mit
einem Pro kopfeinkommen von 550 $ im
Jahr das Land belegte über viele Jahre
im Human Development Index den letzten
Platz weltweit und kann es sich einfach
nicht leisten noch weniger Geld für
Gesundheit Bildung Infrastruktur und
soziale Dienste zur Verfügung zu haben
natürlich könnte die Militärregierung
versuchen mit den Franzosen zu pokern um
zum Beispiel bessere Bedingungen bzw
teilweise ganz einfach eine gerechtere
und nachhaltigere Regelung und höre
Umweltstandards für die Ausbeutung
seiner natürlichen Ressourcen
auszuhandeln Niger beklagt schließlich
schon seit langem dass es an den
Erträgen des uranum goldbergbaus nicht
in ausreichendem Maße beteiligt wird
jedoch die volle Last der ökologischen
und sozialen Kosten trägt es hat
Frankreich beispielsweise vorgeworfen zu
niedrige Preise für sein Uran zu zahlen
die schätzungsweise nur ein Drittel des
Marktpreises betragen obwohl seine
Qualität hervorragend sei den nigerische
Regierung behauptet auch schon lange das
Frankreich nicht genug in die
Entwicklung des nigerischen Bergbau
Sektors investiere und nicht genug
Technologie und Know-how mit Niger
geteilt habe darüber hinaus hatten ja
auch bedenken hinsichtlich der
Gesundheit und Sicherheit seine Arbeit
und Bevölkerung geäußert jeder Strahlung
und Verschmutzung durch den Bergbau
ausgesetzt sind ja es ist klar dass
diese Art und Weise in der die Franzosen
ihr bergbaugeschäft im Niger betreiben
äußerst fragwürdig ist das haben wir
vorhin schon festgestellt die Frage ist
jedoch ob es sich die neue
Militärregierung überhaupt leisten kann
mit Paris neu zu verhandeln oder gab
Bedingungen zu diktieren denn die
Antwort darauf lautet ganz unabhängig
davon wer Präsidentenpalast ist nein
zumindest nicht auf absehbare Zeit am
besten lässt sich dich daran ablesen wie
die Märkte auf den Putsch reagiert haben
tatsächlich ist der Uranpreis seit dem
Staatsstreich in Niger nur leicht
gestiegen die Gründe hierfür sind klar
und es gibt gleich mehrere davon zum
einen hat die EU diesmal in Sachen Uran
ihre Hausaufgaben gemacht und sich gut
abgesichert ihrer strategischen
uran-reserven reicht für ganze 7 Jahre
bei der üblichen Halbwertszeit
nigerischer Regierungen kann man in
Brüssel und Paris also ruhig Däumchen
drehen und abwarten bis sich das Problem
eventuell von selbst löst oder eben
durch die Eco was die
Verhandlungsposition ist Niger ist
momentan auch deswegen ungünstig weil
während der letzten 10 Jahre sowieso ein
Überangebot an Natur Oran Hersteller und
bis aus Natur Uran geeignetes
Brennmaterial entsteht muss es sowieso
einen komplexen und langwierigen Prozess
durchlaufen es dauert also relativ lange
bis sich Ausfälle am Anfang der
nuklearen Brennstoff Lieferkette an
ihrem Ende also dem Strommarkt auswirken
würden wie gesagt sind die europäischen
Reserven üppig und die Energiekonzerne
hätten genügend Zeit einen Lieferstopp
abzufedern und die Lieferketten neu zu
gestalten dann ohne die Niger den
größten Schaden würde also Niger davon
tragen und der letzte Grund für die
schlechte Position der neuen
Militärregierung in ihrem mai ist die
Frage ob sie überhaupt die Macht hätte
einen von ihr beschlossenen Exportstopp
nach Frankreich durchzusetzen der
nigerische Bergbau ist nämlich fast
komplett um die über 1.500
Straßenkilometer bzw 18 Autostunden
entfernte Stadt im Norden des Landes
konzentriert und praktischerweise
befindet sich dort auch der
internationale Frachtflughafen über den
die geförderten Bodenschätze ausgeflogen
werden und wenn man sich das Straßenfest
erkennt man schnell dass es außerhalb
der Hauptstadt nie im ganzen Land kaum
richtige Straßenverbindungen gibt außer
jenen neuen hochwertigen Straßen die von
den minenarten zum Flughafen führen
gleiches gilt für Kraftwerke
Stromtrassen Warenlager und so weiter
und sofort um alle konzentriert sich
quasi die gesamte Infrastruktur des
Landes außerhalb der Hauptstadt oder
Süden des Landes ist in Sachen
Stromversorgung auch noch von niggeria
abhängig Niger Eco was verschärft
Sanktionen
Kommentar fordert Energieversorgung die
von General schiani geführte Hunter hat
die Aufhebung der Stromsperre gefordert
die von der nigerianischen
Bundesregierung im Rahmen des Embargos
gegen die Putschisten verhängt wurde die
ehemals dünn besiedelte Bergbauregion um
arlet ist ein Staat im Staate und dann
muss sich dort nicht sonderlich darum
scheren was im weit entfernten ni Armee
abgeht oder wer dort gar im
Präsidentenpalast sitzt warum nun ratet
mal wo sich die vorhin erwähnte
Militärbasis der Franzosen befindet
Bingo ebenfalls in Arnet und nicht nur
das erinnert ihr euch noch daran wie ich
erwähnt habe dass noch eine zweite
westliche macht ein militär-kontingen im
Niger unterhält nun diese zweite macht
sind die iOS auf ey ihre drohnenbasis
operiert vom Flughafen adlit aus und
insgesamt sind dort in US Militärbasen
mehr als 100 stationiert ebenfalls vor
Ort befindet sich eine geheime cia-basis
nur um sicherzugehen es stellt sich
daher tatsächlich die Frage inwieweit
die Militärregierung in Ihrer Nähe also
überhaupt die reale Kontrolle über die
wirtschaftlich dominante Bergbau Region
hat und weil die Regierungen in Paris
und die Antwort auf diese Frage zu
kennen scheinen haben sie auch keinen
direkten Handlungsdruck nur weil im
Präsidentenpalast kein demokratisch
gewählter Präsident mehr sitzt im Moment
setzt das Weiße Haus auf den
diplomatischen Weg trotz aller
Forderungen Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
Nigers abgesetzter Führer sagt er sei
eine Geisel und fordert die USA auf den
Putsch zu stoppen der gestürzte
Präsident bat sogar in einem Brief an
die Washington Post um eine
us-militärintervention warum hat aus dem
Keller des Präsidentenpalastes indem er
gefangen gehalten wird gar einen Tweet
abgesetzt und mit Anthony blinken schaut
Michelle und Joseph Morell telefoniert
dennoch machen wieder das Weiße Haus
noch die Europäische Union derzeit große
Anstalten die Demokratie in ihrem mai
mit Militär Gewalt wiederherstellen zu
wollen aus all den vorgenannten Gründen
sind sie einfach besser beraten den
afrikanischen Mächten den Vortritt zu
lassen sie hoffen dass sie es sich
leisten können abzuwarten bis sich das
Problem quasi von selbstlos bzw Eco was
intern gelöst wird aber können sie das
wirklich was wenn sich die 100 doch
länger an der Macht hält diese dann im
ganzen Land inklusive festigt und ihre
Agenda dann komplett durchziehen kann
denn wisst ihr was die neuen Machthaber
wissen ganz genau welchen Platz der
[__] in der Welt einnehmen soll und wer
seine Verbündeten sein werden Hörzu
[Musik]
jenseits des neuen Eisernen Vorhangs
die militärunter ist von Mali und
Burkina Faso zeigen uns wie der moderne
afrikanische Putschist vorgehen sollte
als erstes wird die ehemalige
Kolonialmacht auf wieder erdenkliche
Weise angegriffen und zum Sündenbock
erklärt sie muss unbedingt für jeden
erdenklichen Missstand im Land
verantwortlich gemacht werden im Falle
Nigers haben wir euch bereits einige
Beispiele gezeigt aber wartet noch einen
Moment der degeneräle könnten noch mehr
gegen Frankreich Unternehmen in Mali z.B
haben Sie Französisch als Amtssprache
abgeschafft und sowohl hier als auch in
Burkina Faso haben sie alle
französischen Truppen ausgewiesen die
dort im Kampf gegen den terrarismus
Unterstützung leisteten das Ergebnis
haben wir euch vorhin schon gezeigt der
islamische Terror Namen in beiden
Ländern im Gegensatz zu Mini dazu aber
was soll es das einzige was zählt sind
Stimmungen Haltungen und Ideologie nicht
Ergebnisse der nächste Schritt ist dann
sich entsprechend dieser Philosophie in
der heutigen multipolaren Welt zu
positionieren und den Niger haben sie
ihre Wahl bereits getroffen
mega Schneider eilen nach dem Putsch zur
Herstellung russischer Flaggen die
Putschisten haben in Afrika also einen
Streifen von Militärdiktaturen
geschaffen der sich vom Atlantik bis zum
Roten Meer erstreckt die meisten dieser
Länder sind jetzt eher mit Russland als
mit dem besten verbündet und nicht nur
das sie wollen auch eine Mauer gegen den
einst unangefochtenen westlichen
Einfluss errichten nicht sofort da sie
wie wir gesehen haben noch zu sehr vom
Export in den Westen abhängig sind aber
mit der Zeit könnte sich dies ändern
china möchte hier gute Geschäfte machen
und ist vor allem daran interessiert das
dafür Stabilität herrscht und wenn dies
im Rahmen einer von Peking oder Moskau
statt Paris oder Washington abhängigen
Diktatur der Fall ist umso besser
im Niger könnte Chinas Weg zur
Stabilität von den westlichen
Sicherheits Prioritäten abweichen china
hat große wirtschaftliche Interessen in
der Sahelzone die zunehmend von
militärischen wird in Niger haben
chinesische Unternehmen in Öl und Uran
investiert David Shin China Afrika
Experte und Professor an der Elli auf
international erfähr George Washington
University sagte sowohl Washington als
auch Peking würden sich um politische
Stabilität in der seilzone bemühen
während Washington jedoch die
Zusammenarbeit mit demokratischen
Führern bevorzuge seit Peking bereit
sowohl mit demokratischen als auch mit
autoritären Regierungen zusammen zu
arbeiten um die Stabilität aufrecht zu
erhalten china hat ein aktives
militärisches Engagement in Afrika nie
unterstützt und das wird sich wohl auch
nicht ändern selbst wenn die
französischen und amerikanischen
Streitkräfte aus dem Gebiet verdrängt
werden es ist unwahrscheinlich dass
China die Lücke in diesen immer
typischer werdenden Umfeld füllen möchte
China ist auf der Suche nach großen
Mengen an Uran und sein umfangreiches
Atomprogramm zu unterstützen das von
Energieexperten als das größte und
ambitionierteste der Welt bezeichnet
wird und während die gesagt in den
vergangenen zehn Jahren ein Überangebot
an Natur Oranien und durchweg niedrige
Preise zu verzeichnen waren so dass die
Produzenten wenig Lust hatten in neue
Minen zu investieren oder die Förderung
der bestehenden hochzufahren könnte
Chinas wachsende kernkraftwirtschaft nun
die weltweite Nachfrage beleben und die
Preise in die Höhe treiben erst kurz vor
dem Putsch hat die staatseigene kleiner
nuklear international Iranian
Corporation eine Vereinbarung mit der
nigerischen Regierung über die
Wiederaufnahme der Uranförderung in
einer Mine in aseeleg im Zentrum des
Landes getroffen und dies dürfte erst
der Anfang sein wenn es geht hier mehr
um die langfristige Entwicklung denn um
schnelle hauruckerfolge denn die
kernenergiebranche funktioniert in sehr
langen planungsaufbau investitions- und
amortisationszyklen wir haben auf unsere
schwester-kanal visual economic mal ein
Video darüber gemacht wieso genau diese
langen investitionszeiträume bei mehr
für die Niedergang der kein Energie sei
den 80er Jahren verantwortlich sind ganz
genau sie sind der Hauptgrund dafür dass
es mit der Kernkraftwerk abgeht nicht
etwas Sicherheitsbedenken das
Abfallproblem oder reaktorunfälle ich
werde euch dieses interessante Video
verlinken damit ihr es euch später
ansehen könnt aber zurück nach Niger
bisher gibt es keinerlei Hinweise darauf
dass Russland direkt oder über Wagner an
den Vorbereitungen des Staatsstreich in
nieder beteiligt war jetzt aber wo sich
eine russlandfreundliches Regime an die
Macht gepusht hat sind beide bereit
davon zu profitieren Wagner bereitet
sich in Afrika wie ein Virus aus und ist
daher daran interessiert dass die
Militär herunter an der Macht bleibt und
niedriger Russland waren vor
Militäraktionen überall wo die
wagnergruppe hinkam gab es tot
Zerstörung und Ausbeutung die
Unsicherheit ist gestiegen nicht
gesunken es wiederholt sich das was in
anderen Ländern geschehen ist wo sie nur
übel ist mit sich gebracht haben Anthony
blinken wo es Außenminister
die Filter der wagnergruppe sind Teil
des dienstleistungskatalogs den Russland
bei seinen diplomatischen Verhandlungen
anbietet auf diese Weise schafft Wagner
eine Präsenz in Ländern wie zum Beispiel
Mali wo autoritäre Regime pregorians
Männer anheuern um ihre Drecksarbeit zu
erledigen und währenddessen verdrängt
der Kreml den Westen als einflussreiche
macht in der Region putin ist sehr an
Afrika interessiert wie er auf dem
Gipfel in St Petersburg gezeigt hat
alles deutet also darauf hin dass
brigorian seine Operation auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent fortsetzen wird
solange er für Putin Zwecke nützlich
bleibt und ihr habt am Anfang des Videos
gesehen dass die Militär und davon
nieder die wagnergruppe um Hilfe gebeten
hat schließlich hat diese handfeste
Referenzen vorzuweisen die Söldnertruppe
hat bereits die Kontrolle über die Gold
und Diamanten Minen in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik in Mali
und im Sudan übernommen und was hält nie
gehört für Wagner interessantes bereit
nun hauptsächlich goldmähen und wohl
auch Erdöl tatsächlich wollte nieger
seine bescheidene Produktion in diesem
Jahr verfügbar waren da kämen russische
Spezial Christen eventuell gerade recht
natürlich im Paket mit den
schutzleistungen der wagnersöldner
diejenigen unter euch die regelmäßig
visualpolitik schauen wissen das Wagner
immer auf Profit aus ist tja und was ist
mit dem nigerischen Uran Europa das Uran
aus dem Niger vor zu enthalten würde
Putin ein Lächeln ins Gesicht zaubern
aber für die russischen zöldner wäre ein
Angriff auf die französischen und
amerikanischen Truppen in Arlett wohl
mehrere Nummern zu groß ihre Erinnerung
daran was bei ihrem letzten Zusammenstoß
mit den Amis 2018 in Syrien passiert ist
dürfte noch Hellbach sein die russischen
Söldner griffen damals aufgrund der
Inkompetenz ihrer Kommandeure eine
us-stellung an die GIS antworteten mit
einer massiven Welle von Luftangriffen
die die Söldnertruppe zerrieb bevor sie
sich zurückziehen konnte und fickten
dann die verbliebenen Kämpfer mit
Appetit Hubschraubern von Platz ca 300
Wagen das sollten dabei getötet die
Verluste auf der amerikanischen Seite
betrunken exakt 0
sie haben uns unseren verfluchten Arsch
aufgerissen ein Trupp hat verdammt noch
mal 200 Mann verloren und das sofort ein
anderer hat zehn Leute verloren und ich
weiß nicht wie es mit dem dritten Trupp
aussieht aber sie wurden auch ziemlich
übel zugerichtet drei Trupps wurden
zerschlagen die Yankees griffen an erst
haben sie uns mit Artillerie in den
Arsch [__] und dann haben sie vier
Hubschrauber hochgeholt und uns mit
schweren Kaliber durch den verfickten
Fleischwolf gedreht ein Wagner sollten
da überlebt hat ja es ist halt doch
etwas anderes gegen eine ausgewachsene
moderne Armee im taktischen komponierten
gesichtsverbund zu kämpfen als gegen
einen haufene Rebellen dessen sind sich
die Futuristen India may bewusst die Eco
was Intervention könnte nicht nur für
sie eine ernsthafte Bedrohung darstellen
sie könnten einen Flächenbrand in der
ganzen Region auslösen alles deutet
nämlich darauf wenn das dem Militärs in
[__] im Falle einer Intervention nicht
alleine da stehen würden
so und Mali sagen einem
Militärintervention in Niger wäre eine
Kriegserklärung die nigerische Armee
alleine verfügt über eine Streitmacht
von mindestens 20.000 Soldaten für eine
erfolgreiche Militäroperation gegen sie
wäre eine Interventionstruppe von
mindestens 50.000 Mann erforderlich
falls sich die nubu und die Eco was also
nicht eine Schlappe einfangen wollen
sind Sie gut beraten keine kleidergruppe
in den Niger zu entsenden die Armee Chef
der 15 Eko war starten sind sich dessen
bewusst und werden zu konkreten
Planungen der Intervention am Donnerstag
und Freitag dieser Woche in Ghana
zusammenkommen und wird es danach dann
zum Showdown kommen zwischen den
demokratischen Nationen Afrikas und den
Diktaturen Algerien und Guinea haben
zwar ihre Ablehnung gegenüber einem
militärischen Intervention angedeutet
aber die Eco was insgesamt unter der
Führung des Giganten Nigeria übt
weiterhin Druck auf dem Militär
Herunterfahren aus indem sie die
Mobilisierung ihre Reservekräfte
angeordnet hat um die verfassungsgemäße
Ordnung in Niger wieder herzustellen ein
solcher Konflikt droht dann viele
afrikanische Länder direkt zu toll Viren
da sie bereits erklärt haben dass sie zu
den Waffen greifen werden um ihre
jeweiligen Positionen zu verteidigen und
vielleicht weiß er die Angst davor die
die Putschisten dann doch bewogen hat
ihren Ton abzumildern und
Verhandlungsbereitschaft zu
signalisieren
putschistenführer aus Niger erklärt sich
zu direkten Gesprächen mit Eco was
bereit eine Gruppe nigerianischer Islam
Gelehrter die sich mit den pochisten aus
Niger getroffen haben erklärte der
generalhabe sich zu direkten Gesprächen
bereit erklärt um das Pat mit den
westafrikanischen Führern zu lösen die
Lage bleibt also angespannt und wir
werden euch über diesen Aufgaben in
Konflikt auf dem Laufenden halten jetzt
kennt ihr aber zumindest alle relevanten
Hintergründe und können so alle
folgenden tagesaktuellen Nachrichten
besser einordnen und deswegen sind die
Fragen nun erstmal an euch gerichtet
glaubt ihr das ist der Eco was gelingen
wird die Demokratie in Niger wie der
herzustellen werden die Wagner soll da
die Polizisten verteidigen oder sich
einfach nur die Goldminen unter den
Nagel reißen wie sollten sich Frankreich
um die USA Verhalten oder sollte es den
Afrikanern vorbehalten bleiben auf ihrem
Kontinent für Ordnung zu sorgen wie
immer sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja geht uns bitte ein Like als mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen natürlich von unserer jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]